[Applause]
oh I'm telling you nobody here can I can
I tell you my favorite part cuz I was
reading her a pre-interview and like all
the things like I've seen you in Book of
Mormon I've seen been frozen or heard
you in froze all the things that you
don't tell him what you know when you
mentioned new girl that's our pool thank
you you're too young you are so
unbelievably talented
thank you listening to your song in the
car this morning I don't know my name
and I I'm blown away by your mesmerizing
really shocked you shouldn't lose that
though I think it's cool when you get so
excited about meeting people I'm 37
years old I still ask Meryl Streep I
look like an idiot but I have whatever I
don't care
Miley said mine was Harrison Ford
imagine how that went oh my god would be
quiet I literally was like I love you
and he's like all right so why bear claw
why was that your boy I love new girls I
actually just did an interview with
Zooey Deschanel oh I love is like a
die-hard New Girl fans but they told me
on the phone they were like okay it's so
like someone's gonna be sitting with you
on the couch and I'm like oh okay and so
they were like oh I was like who is it
and they were like Josh GAD I was like
who's that so I didn't know who that was
so I'm like a huge fan but I know you as
bear claw so there are so many emotions
that I'm going through right
nito who you were then when I learned me
where I cried I know what you mean
though cuz I don't ever know everybody's
real name especially an actor on the
same way yeah and I always think that
they're the person they were in the
movie and they're not oh yeah what we're
celebrating Thanksgiving those two ways
before the Happy Thanksgiving yeah what
are you thankful for this year my family
of course
yeah thankful for my family they're very
strong I hear you're making a special
dish though this Thanksgiving yes
oh my god okay so I just learned well
not just I've been learning how to cook
because I don't know I just really
wanted to be like that girl just like
cooking let's see me music like I don't
even care by the way I love people who
cook like oh oh okay thank you Kevin
thank you very much Kevin what's up
don't look I'm not
[Music]
I listen I listen to my guests that's my
water by the way so what is it it's
lasagna so Sonia I've never heard of
lasagna soup it's Sonia made into us so
do you wait wait you see and I look at
it now yes okay did you just play a game
of mad libs and we're like it's from
last night and I don't know how they
prepared it okay it would be weapon to
you in the kitchen I was in the kitchen
I mean everything absolutely good but
like imagine if soup oh that's called
pasta so wait we did it wrong I do it I
do it incorrectly but that's what now
makes it my secret so it's supposed to
be soup but I always do it perfectly
every single time and it ends up like
that I don't know why you're only 15
though and you just finish your second
EP right I released one EP and this is
your second Volume one
yeah so then there will be a volume - oh
okay this is so volume this is letters
right letter yes yes yes
so wait and now I'm excited for you're
actually acting right and the Disney
play yeah yeah yeah star girl what is
that about
oh it's about this girl named star girl
who was home-schooled and then goes to a
public school so were you nervous to act
that's I hate acting you do absolutely
100% seeing you and yes III get
oh we're not talking about that one
[Applause]
America contractually obligated the damn
show and they made me do that Beach
Blanket movie I did not want to do it I
cried I couldn't get out I hate acting I
love actors I think that it's such a
it's such a gift like nobody's own
Carolyn I gained respect and I lost
respect for actors I your my favorite
guest ever Wow so what is gained and
lost could I possibly get a water at
some point I don't think she drank from
this one what it wouldn't what did you
gain lose like what do you mean so it's
like okay so it's not as much work as I
thought it was gonna be like it's so fun
like it's really like you go to set I
don't know if I just had a weird
experience you can tell me but I
literally went to set there was just
like tons of catering read your lines
and then like hang out with the cast you
had a weird experience I'm fascinated by
how like advanced you are for your age
yeah how are you so mature you didn't
know who I was and we're crying were you
always how many siblings here I have two
siblings and my one sister is 18 and my
other brother is 20 so I've like always
been like this cuz I kind of followed
their age
we have kids like some of your kids are
a little more advanced and you know the
others none of mine none of my kids talk
am I going to make them watch this
interview do that I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop
yep still here not going anywhere I see
you don't walk away from this